so good evening and welcome my name is
Tom Jessel I'm one of the co-directors
of Columbia University's Mortimer B
Zuckerman mine brain behavior Institute
a mouthful but that mouthful belies an
exciting venture that is already exists
and is just beginning and I want to
welcome you on behalf of the mind brain
behavior Institute and the university to
this episode of the Stavros Niarchos
foundation brain insight lecture series
we're very fortunate to have a
representative of the Neos foundation
one of our greatest stalwarts and
supporters here Stelios Vasa lockets
who's sitting at the front and I like a
round of applause for Stella's because
this wouldn't exist without him and the
foundation and the foundation achieves
two things from this MB bi perspective
the first is this lecture series which
highlights topics of general relevance
by picking Columbia University faculty
who are not necessarily involved in the
Institute itself but have things to say
that are of direct relevance to the
broader mission of the Institute but in
addition the Neos foundation has
established a teacher scholar program
that provides high school teachers with
on hands-on experience of the life of
science communication skills that they
can take back to their classroom and
we're very fortunate that many of those
are also here tonight so if you just
wave all you student teachers that are
supported by the New Yorkers foundation
really
and salute your presence here so the
goal of the mine brain behavior
Institute I think as I see it is twofold
one is to discover new things about the
brain in its normal state and the other
is to use those insights to provide
fundamental clarity into brain
mechanisms gone awry and when you think
about disorders and diseases of the
brain they're really two major themes
that have emerged one is the idea that
the outrageous slings and arrows of
fortune have dealt genetic disorders of
nervous system from Alzheimer's to
Parkinson's to schizophrenia and that
world but they're also the disorders
that emerge through the misfortune of
brain trauma and this evening we have
one of Columbia's most distinguished
practitioners in the general area of
bioengineering Berkeley Morrison is the
director of the neuro trauma and repair
laboratory and his research focuses on
the biomechanics of traumatic brain
injury at the cellular and tissue level
trying to identify mechanisms that
permit new and better strategies for
presenting preventing brain injury and
if we think back over the history of
neuroscience its hundred or more year
history then one of the great examples
of that has taught us a lot about normal
brain function has emerged through the
process of neuro trauma what I'm talking
about is an individual called Phineas
Gage who in 1848 was working on a
railroad and was generating an explosive
mixture to pioneer some new rail
in Vermont when something went wrong the
sand wasn't added this mixture exploded
and it drove a tamping iron that was
about three and a half foot long and one
and a quarter inches wide straight
through his brain and this is Phineas
Gage on the left some many years after
this event holding the tamping iron in
his hand you can see that his left eye
has suffered a little bit and on the
right are reconstructions of the
trajectory of this tamping iron through
the cheek and through the brain and on
the right hand side extreme is the
neural substrate the frontal lobe that
was on the left side severely damaged by
this traumatic episode and what we learn
from that
through studying the back and
miraculously gage survived this you know
in their various theories sister and he
got in the hands of Harvard anatomist
and physiologist who studied him left
right and center and what became clear
is that although slightly controversial
is his mood changed as a function of
this injury and that began the first
studies that placed the prefrontal
cortex as an important component in mood
disorders and gage survived he not only
survived but he became a stagecoach
driver in California in Chile eventually
succumbing some 12 years after the
injury to epilepsies but if you needed
better evidence that neuro trauma is
relevant to the understanding of brain
science you need to look quite hard so
Phineas Gage not everybody who suffers
brain trauma is as you know dramatic as
gage at least from our perspective as
observers but for the individuals
affected neuro trauma is a dramatic
disorder there some 50,000 individuals
who die of traumatic brain injury every
year with another eighty thousand or
something who are severely debilitated
by these brain insults and so we need as
a society as a university as a research
group to understand more effectively the
root causes of traumatic brain injury in
a way that will permit us to design
better therapies for these disorders and
I'm very pleased to introduce Barclay
Morrison to you this evening who will
explain this complicated world of
disorder from the clarity and
perspective of a biomechanical engineer
so Barclay welcome good evening
everybody can all hear me okay sure
should be fine
thank you very much Tom for that
wonderful introduction thank you for the
mbb I for inviting me here as well as
the Niarchos foundation for sponsoring
the event
as Tom said I'm gonna be talking tonight
about biomedical engineer a ninja but
from a slightly different perspective
than maybe common in this venue really
from the perspective of biomedical
engineer and and I hope to share with
you some some insights that can be
gleaned from that different perspective
and and and how we are trying in my lab
to reduce some of the societal costs
that that Tom spoke about before I get
into this just a little interactive
piece here how many people in the
audience either have had a traumatic
brain injury themselves or know somebody
who has it it actually is
and sometimes you need to think about it
for a second and even in our own lives
it doesn't get really the the publicity
the the understanding or interest that
that it really should that it's it's
such a significant and widespread has
widespread incidents myself I'm getting
ready for this talk thinking back over
my younger years I've had at least three
head injuries that I can remember third
grade at the gym at school running
around running backwards I tripped over
somebody's foot and I landed square on
the back of my head it was kind of dazed
don't remember that I went back to class
after recess and about twenty minutes
sitting there at the desk and I started
to get tunnel vision basically I had
damaged my visual cortex with a blood
supply there enough that the arteries
were spasming it was shutting down the
blood supply to my visual cortex and and
that's where I had hit my head your
visual cortexes in the back and and I
was getting tunnel vision because those
cells were basically shutting down you
know told the teacher she sent me to the
nurse told me have laid down for about
20 minutes until my vision came back and
sent me back to school put me back in
the classroom something similar happened
about a year later playing around
outside the ground was wet slipped tried
to stop slip hit the back of my head and
again same thing happened 20 minutes
later tunnel vision waited another 20
minutes it came back but both of these
were fairly serious head injuries that
you know at the at that time the
attitude was just you know shake it off
it's not a big deal that you know
there's no blood so you didn't really
get hurt you know you can't see anything
so and you know that's not what anybody
told me that was just you know the
mindset at the time even today it's it's
pretty similar
other than the third one was skiing
maybe 15 went over a little jump the
tips of my skis hit the ground first
flew my head over and and bounced it off
of some ice and the rest of and we were
there was a ski trip with a bunch of
friends no adults and so I don't
remember the
to that day I had a fairly good
concussion my friends tell me you know
yeah that one side of your face was a
little kind of droopy so again you know
didn't go to the hospital didn't do
anything about it
you know skied down the mountain I don't
I don't remember if I skied the rest of
the day on that so I've had three I know
people who have died from their head
injuries more serious ones so if you'd
begin to think about it it's it's really
prevalent and yet we really don't give
it the the weight that it deserves so
today I'm going to tell you a little bit
about traumatic brain injury I'll start
with some definitions talk about some
statistics about the prevalence some of
the numbers that Tom mentioned tried to
dispel a couple of misconceptions that
are widely held and widely propagated
even by neurosurgeons on CNN and then
I'm going to talk about some of the work
that we do in the laboratory where we
are trying to reduce the societal cost
of TBI as tom said both through
strategies of prevention as well as
through developing new treatments for
the head injured patient so just to
define to start with a traumatic brain
injury is really just any disruption of
normal brain function that's due to a
physical event a mechanical event so a
stroke is not a traumatic brain injury
things like you know due to a blow to
the head even acceleration deceleration
that causes your brain to deform inside
the skull could lead to a TBI anything
that penetrates the the brain and even
shockwaves can cause to traumatic brain
injuries these be arising from Falls
motor vehicle accidents are a major
source of tbis bicycle crashes in the
city pedestrian injuries sports injuries
injuries we'll talk about a little more
in detail and explosions this is just
sort of the breakdown up here this is
not a human brain it's a cow brain
actually but pretty similar to looking
to a human brain
and this is some of the breakdown of
incidence of traumatic brain injury the
cutter causes some motor vehicle
accidents account for about 15% of the
total incidents but actually account for
about half of all TBI deaths some of the
statistics it's how wide of a problem is
traumatic brain injury estimated that
there's almost two million head injuries
in the US alone these are us numbers in
the US every year resulting in about 1.4
million emergency room visits almost
300,000 hospitalizations so long term at
least overnight stays in the hospital
and these are two of the numbers Tom
threw out out of these head injuries
every year and there's fifty eighty-five
thousand people who have a permanent
disability because of the head injury
and these are people who are going to
need extra care or have a deficit for
the rest of their lives
because of the head injury and then an
additional 52 thousand deaths every year
now these numbers may not seem like huge
numbers certainly cancer heart disease
kill more people every year but this is
this is one of the astonishing facts
about traumatic brain injury is that it
really strikes people in the prime years
of their lives so between the ages of 15
and 55 year old years old accounts for
80% of all the traumatic brain injuries
so these people all told today there's
about 5.3 million Americans who live
with the permanent disability due to a
traumatic brain injury because of when
they've gotten this TBI that's that's
about 3 percent of the u.s. population 2
to 3 percent of the u.s. population it's
a huge number and because it strikes
people in the you know productive years
of their lives these people also then
need in some cases 24-hour care
round-the-clock care
it's the the cost of traumatic brain
injury is massive it's you know seventy
six point five billion estimated by the
CDC every year so it really it doesn't
get much publicity it's been getting
more awareness recently with some cases
we'll talk about but but it's a it's a
major health problem in the US that then
often goes unnoticed it's it's an it's
been called a silent epidemic
by multiple sources over the years so in
all of this a concussion is also a
traumatic brain injury it's a mild
traumatic brain injury although that's a
little bit of a misnomer a concussion
getting your bell rung seeing stars
being a little woozy after getting hit
in the head is a traumatic brain injury
most of these are from sports playing
sports about 300,000 adult sports
related injuries concussions every year
and and most of the Simpson symptoms
from a concussion will spontaneously
resolve themselves but one of the
problems with a concussion is that after
having a concussion you're more
vulnerable to getting a second
concussion whether that's your incidence
goes up I think about fivefold from your
first concussion after your first
concussion for getting a second one and
up something like tenfold after the
second one to get a third one and and
when you get that second or follow-on
concussion the the deficits that you
suffer are much worse so whether it's
motor function verbal memory visual
memory reaction time coordination or you
know whatever nor degeneration there may
be that second injury that third injury
for the same impact is going to have a
bigger effect on your on your brain and
there's been many high highly publicized
cases over the last few years of sports
concussions in particular football being
the most intense contact sport that
Americans play you know stories of high
school students in this case he had a an
initial head injury a couple days before
he was playing in a game actually nobody
hit him he missed a tackle hitting his
own head on the on the turf and a few
hours later he was dead because that in
that case of something called second
impact syndrome but he had a second head
injury while he was still symptomatic
from the
first one and this forget his name
quarterback signed with the NFL
multi-million dollar contract and he
decided to not play football because he
was worried about his long-term
neurological health and then this is jr.
say oh who actually committed suicide by
shooting himself in the chest so he
could donate his brain and he was
diagnosed with this this chronic
neurodegenerative disease called chronic
traumatic encephalopathy we used to call
this punch-drunk syndrome because it was
only seen in boxers as you might imagine
they take many blows to the head and
they develop some characteristic
neuropsychiatric deficits as well as
have a particular nor a pathological
signature in their brains on autopsy and
and now we're seeing this there are many
professional athletes who have been
donating the brains to science after
they died and we're seeing a lot of this
chronic signs of chronic traumatic
encephalopathy in professional athletes
and it's believed to be from concussive
but even sub concussive events that are
cumulative over their their professional
careers or even amateurs they've got
amateurs in the brain bank now as well
so let me dispel a myth that gets
propagated all the time because Hutchins
is a brain injury people think of it as
getting your bell rung or getting a ding
but the truth of the matter is that if
they break so I agree with him they're
in your head bell rung the biggest
thought that concussion is is getting
hit to the head but it can happen in all
sorts of different ways it can happen
certainly on sports field you know how
about the helmet collision for example
but it can also happen in ways that you
might not expect for example in a car
accident even if your head doesn't hit
the dashboard or hit the windshield just
the violent moving back and forth of the
brain within the skull during a car
accident for example can cause a
concussion
I agree with that as well people think
for example if this is the brain around
it as a skull and then you have a helmet
that there's a blow and everything just
you just get a blow to the brain that's
not exactly what's happening typically
if all of a sudden this brain is moving
this direction another helmet for
example is moving this direction and
then they both suddenly stop what
happens is brain keeps moving within the
skull bounces back and forth almost like
a beach ball in a swimming pool at the
same yeah your brain is not a beach ball
it doesn't bounce around inside your
skull I this gets propagated by
neurosurgeons it gets propagated by
physicians and it's it's categorically
just not true and let's let's find out
why so the brain by composition by by
material what it's made up of is about
80% water 10% protein 10% fat it's
pretty similar to fresh wet meat chicken
breast or soft tofu if you're a
vegetarian and then meat tofu is much
stiffer than your brain is orders of
magnitude stiffer than your brain in
fact bringing your brain has similar
mechanical properties to soft butter
warm butter warm fat so imagine it's do
it a mental experiment for me take that
piece of tofu or chicken breast and slam
it on the kitchen counter as hard as you
can is that gonna bounce no it's not
gonna bounce it is not a super ball your
brain is not a super ball your brain
does not bounce around inside your skull
it undergoes deformation because of the
acceleration and forces that are applied
to it and so there's deformations well
so what is it that that causes the
injury so here we've got a again a
physical demonstration I didn't bring it
with me but we can envision this
straight forward you can do this at home
we've got a dish a bowl it's filled with
jello and much softer jello than the
jello you eat so gelatin 0.5 percent by
weight the jello you eat is about 10
times stiffer and we've just poured it
in here we let it set and we
we painted a grid on it and we want to
take that so this is our skull the bowl
is our skull and the jello on the inside
is our brain and if we take that bowl
and we move it linearly just slide it
straight on the countertop the the brain
on the inside is actually not going to
deform that much and that's true for
your own brain the brain is because of
the high content of water is basically
incompressible and unless we get the
outer rigid case our skull to change
shape then the brain on the inside is
not going to deform from linear
accelerations if on the other hand
because it's so soft it's incompressible
but it's very soft if on the other hand
we take it and we spin the bowl this is
what's going to happen so I didn't
Photoshop this this really is I spun the
bowl and I took a picture of it you can
see that the squares get turned into
diamond shapes and what's happening here
is that rather than a change in volume
to cause deformation we're getting a
change in shape the volume stays
constant and so we get a compression in
one direction and we get a stretch in
the in another direction
in such a way that the volume stays the
same and that's what's happening here
this is what happens in a head injury in
a car accident a fall any closed head
injury this is what's happening we get a
change in shape of the brain that leads
to shear strain but we don't get a
change in volume so that's what happens
so what do you dr. Gruber was talking
about the accelerations it's true you
don't need to get hit in order to have
your head accelerate rotationally like
this and in that process this is gonna
happen to your brain so next time you
see sanjay gupta dr. Gupta on the street
you can tell him he's wrong and you can
explain to him the right way what really
happens so so in a car accident a fall
this is a crash-test dummy over here on
the left
it's a side impact test that's the
initiator right this is the mechanical
event that initiates traumatic brain
injury these accelerations cause the
brain to deform this is a computational
model of
if the dummy had a brain this is what
would be happening to the brain these
colors here blue represents the original
state red represents a 25% shear strain
basically something increasing its
length by 25% and so it's this is the
initiator the mechanical event that
causes the traumatic brain injury and we
can divide that brain injury into two
main categories there's a primary injury
as if something were broken by pulling
on it as if we pulled on a rubberband
too far and it snapped we call that a
primary injury and that will occur in
some of the most severe car accidents
where somebody is killed instantly we
can get tears in the brain but the far
majority of the damage after head injury
is caused by what we call secondary
injury where the tissue gets
mechanically stimulated and that sets in
motion a whole series of biological
cascades steps in correct activation of
proteins which results in a delayed
fashion over minutes hours and days for
cells to die to become dysfunctional but
this is the initiating event down at the
tissue level and then from there we get
a biological response that can take time
to develop so what we studied in my
laboratory falls under two main areas
the first is prevention of TBI trying to
improve safety systems to prevent the
injuries in the first place and here
we're really talking about reducing that
energy transfer from the environment
whether it's throwing something against
the wall or a car accident but
prevention is all about reducing the
energy transfer from the environment to
our brains which in turn reduces the
deformation of the brain tissue which in
turn will reduce whatever injury or even
prevent the injury from from occurring I
mentioned a third of all head injury
deaths TBI deaths are due to motor
vehicle accidents and so a lot of effort
has gone into reducing motor vehicle
accidents through engineering better
safety systems seatbelts work we have
very sophisticated seatbelts
days they pre tension they actually pull
you back into place the appropriate
place in the car so that you can take
advantage of the protection around you
it all happens you know you in
milliseconds airbags work terrifically
and the the design of the cars has
improved tremendously the idea here is
it looks like a terrible crash right but
but that's because the car was damaged
not because the occupant on the inside
was damaged and so all of this is
crumple zones and and it eats up all of
that energy before it gets to the
occupant and you know in the 50s a car
would be in an accident the driver would
be dead and they'd hose off the
windshield and they'd sell it to the
next guy cars don't do that anymore
because they actually protect the people
on the inside our second area focuses is
trying to develop new therapies for the
head injuries that do a car we're not
always going to be able to prevent all
head injuries and so we need to better
treat those patients and as I said the
majority the cell death really occurs
over hours and days after the injury and
a minority of it occurs at the time of
impact and because of that delayed
fashion it gives us this opportunity to
try to treat that ongoing progression to
break it from that initial stimulus to
eventual cell death we've been trying to
come up with new drugs for 3040 years
now and traumatic brain injury they've
been over 30 phase 3 clinical trials
that have run all the way through the
FDA process and we've gotten nothing
there are no drugs for head injured
patients there's nothing so don't get a
head injury because there's really
nothing we can do neurosurgeons are
great they can pull mass lesions out so
they can stop bleeding but they can't
treat the underlying pathology of the
head injury some drugs have gotten close
just maybe six months months ago a
progesterone trial was was cancelled so
we've got we've got nothing so
prevention today is the best way to
reduce the societal cost of TBI and then
we're looking to
new therapies for head injury for those
that do happen so so that's kind of
intro what I want to turn to now is to
talk a bit about how we study traumatic
brain injury in the lab and obviously
there's many different ways that
scientists can tackle a complex problem
like this each has advantages and
disadvantages to it but I want to talk
to you about what we do how we've
approached this so you can envision
studying this clinically you know you do
epidemiological studies or Hospital
studies human studies you can envision
doing this with animals animal models
we've taken a different approach and
I'll explain why but ours is based on a
tissue culture model we can keep brain
cells alive in a dish and we can apply
precise mechanical stimuli to those
living brain cells so we can control the
biomechanics we can control the
environment that the cells are in very
precisely and that and you'll see why
that's why we do that why that's
important for our work it's really in
one respect to control that biomechanics
very precisely we can reproduce anything
from a bump on the head to a fatal car
accident and even to explosions we have
a shock tube you know in the lab over
here is actually the mainstay in our lab
the device small device it's only you
know loaf of bread size device here
we've got a high-speed camera some
lights this is where our tissue culture
goes this living slice of brain tissue
I'll show you that in a minute and then
this is the injury device and I'll show
you how that works in a second this
camera allows us to verify the
biomechanics of the injury these are
some images of cultures these are brain
slice cultures so we take the brain from
an animal we do have to start with an
animal but make thin slices of that
brain tissue and then we can keep that
tissue alive for literally four weeks we
keep it alive and a dish
for weeks and the advantage so these are
this is a picture of a living part of
the brain called the hippocampus this is
what it looks like when we first see it
in the animal this is what it looks like
after two weeks and culture it maintains
the anatomy the structure all the
different kinds of cells are there that
wired up correctly they're talking to
one another
neurons are firing action potentials and
talking to the neighbors the rest of
these images are all been stained with
different dyes our brains on it blue
they're more fleshy color and then these
are different stains to show that
they're all wired up and this is through
the thickness of the slice so it's it
stays many cell layers thick a fifth of
a millimeter thick so we have this
living slice of brain tissue in a dish
we call this an organic tipic brain
slice culture and with that we we injure
it first we culture it on a on a silicon
membrane we've got one here this is the
size of with what this is up here on the
screen on the bottom it's just a rubber
membrane and we culture that slice of
tissue on this deformable substrate the
rubber membrane and then to injure the
tissue to apply the biomechanics of a of
a head injury we pulled that membrane
down over a cylindrical indenter and in
the process it stretches the membrane
you can see up here the red part is a
tissue that's grown on the membrane and
as we pull this down over the well it
stretches the membrane and by
controlling the speed and the magnitude
how far we stretch that pull that down
we can control the biomechanics anything
from a bump on the head to a severe car
accident and then we pulled the well
down rather than pushing the indenter up
so that the membrane stays in the same
plane of focus so we can actually take
high-speed video of the event so this
whole event takes maybe 40 to 50
milliseconds this isn't the camera
zooming in this is actually the
substrate being stretched and the tissue
getting bigger we only do it one time
this is just looping for so you can see
it but that simulates that deformation
that happens in a car accident or a fall
okay so what is it that we do with this
well one of the things coming back to
the biomechanics and prevention of head
injury one of the things that we do with
our system that we develop is what we
call tolerance criteria basically the
question is how far can we stretch the
brain tissue how much force deformation
can it withstand before it breaks
basically we want to measure how it
responds to the mechanical stimulus and
determine whether or not it's healthy if
it's functioning after that stimulus or
if it's been damaged and we can do this
with our system because we can precisely
control that injury stimulus we can
verify it with the high speed video and
because we're doing this all on a living
piece of brain tissue and we're
interested in studying its biological
living response no that all makes sense
right but from a from an engineering
standpoint that's not usually how we
think of things we usually don't think
of things being alive right you give
something to an engineer and the first
thing they're gonna want to do is pull
it apart
they're gonna want to break it and
that's what we normally do when we think
of failure we take a piece of steel we
put it in a testing machine and we pull
on it until it breaks in half we call
that ultimate failure when it does break
and then once we know that information
it tells us something fundamental about
the material and then we can go off and
and build cars or spaceships or bridges
and and be certain that they're not
going to fail that they're going to
withstand whatever forces that we put on
them so this concept though of braking
doesn't really hold for most biological
tissues in our body sure you know
load-bearing structures bone skin even
fracturing and braking probably makes
sense for those but but for non
load-bearing structures like the brain
tearing or breaking doesn't really make
sense so when we talk about failure or
or injury we need to define what kind of
failure what kind of injury we're
talking about and really for the brain
we're either talking about
its ability to think our ability to
think the ability of neurons to do what
they're supposed to do fire action
potentials you know compute on sensory
information that's coming in make a
decision and send that information back
out or we can also talk about cell death
in the brain with it being so highly
cellular eyes so we need to redefine our
failure when we're talking about
something that's alive and so this is
something that we did have published in
the past and we developed what we call
the cell death tolerance criteria and
basically it gives us a relationship
between the amount of mechanical
stimulus that we apply to the tissue and
how much how many of the cells die in
response to that stimulus so here
lagrangian strain is just a fancy
engineering way for quantifying how much
we stretch the brain and over here is
the percent of cell death so for example
that 20% strain stretching something 20%
one of these slices of brain tissue we
get depending upon the region of the
brain we get 35% cell death in one
region of the hippocampus 2025 percent
in another region so what good is that
what how does how can we use this how is
this useful for traumatic brain injury
well from those computational models
that that I introduced from the earlier
slide this is one of the same
computational model where we can predict
how much deformation is our brain is
being subjected to in a car accident we
can compute that very precisely the the
deformations well we can't do from from
this kind of an analysis is to say what
that means in terms of the biology so
what if this part of the brain was
stretched 10% what does that mean in
terms of the function of the brain what
does that mean in terms of the cells
that are that are living there so with
our data we can now take this one step
further and put it into a biological
context and be able to predict how many
cells what percentage of cells will die
in this area which percentage of cells
will be dysfunctional in that
and why is that all important well
because the engineers who are designing
the safety systems the cars the sports
equipment helmets they need something to
design their systems too they need to
know what is the safe limit otherwise
they don't know whether their device is
going to work whether that airbag is
actually going to prevent an injury at
30 miles an hour or not and why this is
so important into some context is that
the current legislated standards that
are promulgated by the the federal
government the National Highway Traffic
Safety Administration are all on base
are all based on something called the
head injury criterion so every car on
the road is its safety standards are
based on this number some number this
number was developed in the 70s and 80s
but it was developed for and it's it's a
measure that's based on the linear
acceleration of a head of a crash-test
dummy in a car but it's it was
originally designed and developed to
predict skull fracture not to predict
anything about the brain not to predict
anything about traumatic brain injury so
all of the cars on the road are actually
designed to stop skull fracture not
traumatic brain injury and so this looks
like quite a violent event here but if
you notice as you look at it most of the
acceleration is all the dummy's head and
rotation there's actually very very
little translational motion of the head
it's all like this and so this passes
this head injury criteria but all of
those finite element models the
computational models I've been showing
you predict over 25 percent strain
throughout the brain because head injury
criterion doesn't take into account any
of that rotational acceleration so
there's a push not only by the federal
government but insurance industry as
well to to develop a new standard that's
based on these computational models that
will take into account not only the
linear but also the rotational
acceleration so that the cars on the
roads will be designed to actually
prevent traumatic brain injuries as
opposed to skull fracture so with our
data
the engineers now know where to set
these limits for the deformation of the
brain when they're building these
systems so that's one example so where
else
where else can our tools take us well as
I said this response to injury is
clearly a biological process so
understanding what that what that
process is going from a mechanical
stimulus to this biological response at
a molecular cellular level is is this
whole field of Meccano transduction
Meccano transduction how is it that a
mechanical stimulus gets turned into a
biological response and so we can use
our systems our tools to understand that
and once we can understand that process
in some detail we can start to identify
therapeutic targets start to rationally
design and develop drugs that prevent
that progression and try to better treat
head-injured patients in the future so I
said earlier that most of that cell
death occurs in a delayed fashion and
here's some data that that shows that we
can reproduce that in our tissue culture
model here we've stretched our piece of
brain tissue to about 20% at 20
reciprocal second strain rate and here
we quantify the cell death using this
red marker red dye and we really don't
see a big increase until 2 to 3 days
after the head injury so that gives us
this time window in here where we might
be able to treat the the tissue to come
up with to prevent that eventual cell
death so as I said earlier that been 30
failed phase 3 clinical trials to date
and many other failed attempts to
develop a new therapy and one of the
things that they've had in common is
that they're all mono therapies they're
a single drug and this is just how not
only the FDA sort of enforces it or the
rules enforce it but drug companies want
to know that they've got a drug that's
very clean it goes after one target has
no off-target effects and and so that's
the way that you know these trials have
been designed it's a very specific drug
with a specific target well you might
imagine that you know the analogy of
throwing a computer against the wall you
know being a car accident is going to do
a lot of bad things
to your brain not just you know one
thing so in the field of traumatic brain
injury there's been a push to test
combination therapies put drugs together
that may have gotten close in these
previous trials close to showing an
effect and combine them together so you
can target multiple pathways
simultaneously and and this has actually
come out of the HIV AIDS therapies where
they're combining multiple drugs
together and and actually keeping people
HIV free for for many years so so we've
done this with our in vitro model we can
use our in vitro model to test new drug
combinations and so here's just one
example of a combination of estrogen the
hormone estrogen and combined with a
drug called memantine which is a
non-competitive NMDA antagonist but it's
used in and youth dependent
it's a FDA approved drug for treating
Alzheimer's disease so the idea is that
if you use fda-approved drugs we will be
able to translate them more quickly so
here's the injury the cell death after
the injury without a drug when we use
estrogen alone it significantly reduces
the effects the cell death memantine on
its own also significantly reduces the
cell death but when we combine them
together we get an even better response
and so you know in future studies we'll
be trying to translate this it's got to
go through animal tests before we can
get it to the clinic but here's an idea
of using the in vitro model testing more
drugs getting them through faster before
testing them in animals also alluded to
earlier this traumatic chronic traumatic
encephalopathy where it's caused by
we're pretty sure it's caused by
repetitive injuries over one's career
over a long term it's has many a large
neuropsychological cascade sequelae to
it but what we don't know about it are
the underlying but biomechanics how many
hits does it take to begin to develop
this pathology what
what's the minimum duration between
those hits so that they're safe how hard
to those hits have to be how many does
it take before you get this there's a
lot of the biomechanics that we don't
understand which we could study in our
dish if we can reproduce this mild
repetitive TBI there's also this as I
alluded to this second impact syndrome
as well where you have a catastrophic
outcome after the first one so we have
shown that we can actually reproduce
this in a dish so our isolated piece of
brain tissue can actually develop this
repetitive injury synergy we can get
worse outcome after a second injury so
here we subjected our tissues to a
single stretch event of about 10% strain
so something low that we know is not
injurious because we've already
developed a tolerance criteria but if we
follow that single event with a second
one 24 hours later we get the
synergistic increase in cell death we
get a lot more cell death what's
interesting though is if we wait 72
hours after the first injury to apply
the second injury we don't get that
synergistic cell death and so this
speaks to the rest periods that athletes
have that that have been now instigated
in in concussion protocols where you
need to sit out a certain amount of time
a week or so where by sitting out we can
prevent this catastrophic second impact
syndrome so now that we have this
reproduced in a dish we're gonna start
we're studying this to try to understand
what not only the biomechanics are that
are behind it but then also what
cellularly changes when you have to
injuries 24 hours apart versus 72 hours
apart and then lastly after single
impacts you know a concussion there's
really no cell death a concussion by
definition has there's no cell death
there's no physical damage to the brain
and that's really the concussion is all
about a disruption of the normal
function typical symptoms after
concussion are feeling confused fuzzy in
the head as well as learning and memory
deficits not being able to concentrate
and so we've asked if we can reproduce
this these learning and memory deficits
in our dish with our tissue so you might
ask how is it possible to study learning
and memory and a bunch of cells in a
dish
a slice of brain tissue well if we think
about what's learning what memory is at
the most basic level what we're really
talking about is a change in the pattern
of neuronal activity a change in pattern
of the the cells in your brain that they
they respond differently to a similar
input and so we can actually measure
that mathematically in our slice
cultures we can put a number to that
looking at how correlated firing is
between between electrodes and then you
might ask how can we induce learning in
a dish well there's well-established
protocols where you can induce a change
in the structure of the activity either
electrically or we're doing this
chemically so we asked if after a head
injury in our dish whether our slice of
brain tissue could learn and remember
things in a similar manner to an
uninjured piece of brain tissue so let
me walk you through this so at baseline
before the injury we can measure this
structural activity in the in the
function of the firing of the neurons
and we'll put some number to it I can
explain it later but let's just put a
number to an arbitrary number we'll call
it learning in memory
so before we teach it anything the slice
doesn't know anything so it's got a low
number then while we're trying to teach
it something we put in a drug that
causes it to burst and change its
activity and and that learning that
structured activity increases so now we
take the drug off and we wait 24 hours
so this is like the learning period take
the drug off wait 24 hours and basically
ask the slice if it remembered what we
taught it during this time and 24 hours
later we've got our uninjured in blue
and our injured in the orange and our
injured cultures don't remember what we
taught them 24 hours ago so we can
reproduce so there's no cell death here
we can measure the cell death
and these are these are mild enough
injuries that were not causing cell
death so it's really a model of
concussion where you don't have that
cell death but you have learning and
memory impairments that we can reproduce
here and now we can use the system to
try to understand what it is that's gone
wrong that's underlying these things so
basically we're following this up now
and we're looking at what are all of
these molecular players it's a very
complicated process and we're trying to
understand what gets broken what of
these players that that are involved in
this restructuring and the activity are
damaged by the mechanical event and the
long-term goal there is once we if we
can identify what is being broken then
maybe we can test drugs that affect
those kind of enzymes or proteins to see
if we can repair the damage
bring that learning and memory ability
back after the injury so to summarize
this is a picture of my lab from the
spring so TBI is a major health care
problem in the United States showed you
some of those numbers concussion getting
your bell rung seeing stars is a
traumatic brain injury and you really
have to take it seriously if you see
Sanjay Gupta on the street tell them the
brain doesn't bounce around inside your
skull and you can explain to them what
it really does and it's possible to
study something as complicated as
traumatic brain injury with a simplified
system in a dish where we can control
things very precisely which will
hopefully give us new insights into
what's going wrong all with the eye
towards trying to reduce the societal
costs of TBI and so if you go home with
just didn't hear anything I said up to
this point if you go home just remember
one thing wear your seatbelts wear your
helmet if you rollerblade ride a bike
these things work and we actually have
there's nothing we can do for you if you
get a head injury it's just the state of
science and just want to close with
acknowledging our funding sources as
well as the graduate students who did
the data who generated the data that I
presented
they're in brown Gwen Mike and Reuben
and previous postdoc Heather thank you
all for your attention and be happy to
take questions
yeah yeah yeah so so the short answer is
no I can write because we haven't so
we're actually trying to Culture the
cerebellum right now in order to be able
to do this kind of a study with it in
vivo animal models clinically we don't
have the resolution to know what's
happened physically to those locations
to you know to compare them
quantitatively to see if one is more
vulnerable than another
what compounds all of this is is
different regions of your brain actually
have different stiffnesses
even we we've measured the mechanical
properties at different regions of the
brain and we find about a fourfold
difference between the softest and the
stiffness stiffest parts of your brain
so not only that tolerance criteria that
you see but then also the mechanical
properties are going to dictate that
overall pattern of damage
and you talk into the microphones and
other people come here yeah you talked
about um physical the head like
following getting hit by it in football
or something but could you talk about
what happens to the brain in a shock
wave an explosion sure definitely so we
study that as well and in the lab and
and it's it's it is a different injury
so explosion of blasts is much more
complex
you have the shock wave the initial
shock wave
you have penetrating fragments
potentially you can be accelerated by
the explosion and or you just fall over
so we know that penetrating is bad your
brain we know that just falling over or
accelerating is what we study here is we
know that's bad for your brain the thing
that that is still a little
controversial still controversial is
whether that shock wave by itself can
damage the brain and from our studies
where we again take a slice culture we
have a shock tube that just generates a
shock wave we can eliminate the
penetration we can eliminate the the
large scale stretching that shock wave
alone we have to go to very high
pressures to get cell death but at
fairly low pressures we can get a
deficit in learning and memory out of
these cultures so so even in the absence
of of your skull being penetrated of
being thrown against the the wall by the
explosion that shock wave itself is
going to have an effect it's going to
affect your ability to learn to
concentrate sleep disturbances are some
of the common symptoms from from
military personnel
I really enjoyed your talk um I was
wondering so in terms of a CCI model
what you have injuries supposed to the
cortex that isn't necessarily very deep
you tend to see a lot of damage in the
hippocampus even on the contralateral
side how far can you model that in
dissection so so we can culture
different regions of the brain we can
culture the cortex and the hippocampus
and as I said we're working on the
cerebellum we do so we wouldn't we don't
have enough tissue in there to have a
contralateral injury but some of our
data does explain why even with CCI
where it impacts the cortex why you get
so much hippocampal damage the
hippocampus is one of the softest
regions of the brain so you push on
something out here and the soft
underlying structure is going to deform
as much or or even more and especially
ca3 is one of the softest regions and
that's where you see a lot of the injury
maybe I can ask your question so we
think we understand a lot about why
nerve cells die the accumulation of
calcium the activation of caspase
pathways or the activation of glutamate
receptors so in your studies where
you're inducing a mechanical deformation
do those agents or things have been
hibbett those pathways benefit and yeah
in stroke trials many people have tried
drugs like MK 801 and maybe they were
so where is the field of taking so so
everything you mentioned has been tried
in TBI
mk2 one works but it has a very very
short therapeutic window you actually
can't get it on board in time to use it
there is a pop tonic cell death after
traumatic brain injury it's probably
only about maybe 10% of the cell death
though the the biggest problem with TBI
is that it's it activates so many
different things simultaneously that in
the past we've always been trying to go
after one target and and it's really
never enough to have a significant
effect on the on the outcome and and
hence why the the field has turned to
this idea of poly therapies of
combination therapies to try to target
multiple cascades simultaneously I was
wondering if you've noticed any actual
physical damage to this the nerve cells
in the brain is the membrane the cell
wall torn is the nucleus just distorted
is there some physical damage that you
can identify so so people have looked at
that there is a theory that's called
Meccano poor asian where you pull on the
cell fast enough and you actually get
pores in the plasma membrane transient
pores and that's part of the initial
cascade that that you know that the
rails the whole train that causes these
problems another avenue is that even
without physical damage just a visual
physical damage you can imagine that you
know inside a cell isn't isn't a balloon
isn't you know a plasma membrane and
everything just tumbles around on the
inside basically everything inside a
cell works on solid-state chemistry
everything stuck to something that
cytoskeletal
the study skeleton that goes through the
whole cellular structure you can imagine
that when you deform that anything
that's stuck on there enzymes different
enzymes are going to get knocked off or
or the change and pressure because of
the deformation changes the dissociation
constant and so your inhibitor of a
protein of an enzyme comes off and it
and it starts a cascade so so even
without having to tear anything we do
see that you can get large enough
deformations to tear things but but we
don't see we're not tearing cells apart
and we still get this delayed cell death
and so that the mechanical transducer
that thing that takes that mechanical
stimulus and turns it into one of many
of these cascades is still unknown
it is thought sort of the first step in
it is we deform a neuron and it releases
glutamate and then that glutamate
releases depolarize as a neuron releases
more glutamate that causes calcium come
in which depolarizes neuron which makes
more glutamate go out and this starts
this feed-forward cascade maybe but
things like MK 201 that stops that
process only works for in the first 15
minutes it doesn't work after that you
can block that calcium coming in but you
don't block cell death later on so and
there's a whole that's a whole host of
things that get activated simultaneously
it really it really is like taking a
hammer to your computer it's a lot of a
lot of bad things happen simultaneously
so you know how when you're riding
roller coasters then you go through
loops and you're upside down and your
body Jurek side to side so that's a good
question it's it's been raised before
you it has no effect on your brain that
has no effect on your brain whatsoever
the the G's that you're pulling the
forces
one two geez maybe it's not enough to do
anything to your brain when you get and
and it does it to me when I get off a
roller coaster I can feel it I feel a
little woozy but it's it's more of the
proprioceptors in your neck that your
neck is fatigued from holding your head
and and that's what's making you woozy
that worry your body knowing where where
it is and itself is in space rather than
causing damage to your brain and the
forces just aren't high enough there
have been some reports in the literature
that even mild or even less than mild
traumatic brain injury long-term can
lead to changes in the brain that are
similar to those occurring in
Alzheimer's and dementia so accumulation
of these tangles and beta amyloid and
things like that so can you keep your
your cultures long enough and have you
begun to think about looking at you know
over weeks yeah yeah that's a great
question it's a great question we can
keep our cultures healthy viable for
maybe four weeks I would say and so we
we tend to look at more acute events and
haven't been looking at some of the
changes that you're talking about also
just because we don't have the expertise
to do it but we have started
collaborating with around CEO at obrr
aanh co-op town with the blast as well
in Blast two to look at long term longer
term changes in tau so so good question
and we're very much interested in it
so you spoke a little bit about teaching
the slices of brain in order to study
how it reacts and how it changes with
memory can you elaborate a little
further yeah sure I can yes so so we we
put the we put the slice cultures on a
micro electrode array it has 60 channels
so 60 electrodes in an array format an
8x8 array without the corner electrodes
so basically it's like sticking 60
needles into the culture to record the
neuronal activity we record for about 3
minutes and we basically identify when
there's activity on an electrode and we
calculate the correlation matrix between
pairs of electrodes and then we
calculate the eigen value the maximum
eigen value from that correlation matrix
and we call that the the synchronization
index and that's what I was calling
learning and memory just rather than go
into all of this during the learning
period we've put by Q : in it's a GABA a
receptor blocker so that the inhibition
and the slice is removed and so you get
all of this excitatory tone and and you
get bursting throughout the slice and
basically LTP comes from coordinated
firing a change in the structure the
circuitry comes from a coordinated
firing but between neurons and so while
we have that drug in there there's a lot
of coordinated firing and that that
synchronization make number goes up the
eigenvalue goes up we wash it out and
see 24 hours later if the the activity
is still correlated if we've got the
same eigenvalue from the matrix and then
the injured ones they didn't they didn't
have the same coordinated activity as
the controls as the uninjured ones 24
hours later interestingly the act
and the injured ones was actually
greater than the uninjured ones so you
might expect the reason why you get that
that value to come down is because
there's just no activity well in fact
the opposite was true the injured ones
that had no coordinated firing were
actually firing more but it was
uncoordinated so that's how we do can
you talk about the difference between
violent impact over a short period of
time versus very very mild impact over a
long period of time and I'm thinking
about sports soccer for example hitting
the pole with your head that was never
considered a problem before but now
people start talking about it yeah
it's a good question so the soccer in
particular so studies have been done
doing sort of neuro psych evaluations of
soccer players over long term compared
to non soccer players athletes and and
they do see some deficits and the soccer
players again the the physical forces of
heading a ball aren't really high enough
and and I think playing soccer and then
there is a correlation between the
players who head the ball more often and
the deficits so at first you might think
it's the amount of heading that you do
but but it's really from head to head
collisions you're hitting the ball more
often you're getting more head to head
collisions and so you know causation
doesn't mean that correlation doesn't
mean causation but I think in that case
in the specific case of soccer those
deficits are from head to head
collisions and not from hitting the ball
the the the g's from heading the ball
are right around the cheese from a
roller coaster so it's okay to play
soccer
so you you Barkley have made a very
compelling case of the crucial
importance of understanding better ways
of treating TBI what you haven't done is
expressed your degree of confidence that
let's say in the next 10 years there
will be interventions that really so how
confident are you that the approach to
understand given the complexities will
lead to therapies and treatments in you
know the space of a decade that's an
unfair question that's why we're trying
to prevent them in the first place as
well 10 years maybe 10 years I think
this idea of combination therapies so we
have had drugs that have gotten close in
the past so one drug a specific target
have gotten close to whatever you know
the statistical criteria were set in
those drug studies and I think people
are going to start going back drug
company is going to start going back
revisiting those and trying to combine
them and I think that is where we will
get some effective therapies in the
short term it is such a complex problem
we've been studying it for a long time
and I think we do have we we know a lot
about it and I think we do have the
background to make rapid discoveries
with this idea of combining drugs
together so at the mind brain behavior
Institute we pride ourselves in taking
care of our faculty and if you think of
Barclays autobiographic introduction
where he was falling to the left and
falling to the right it's quite clear
the work we have to do to make progress
in this general field is protect the
investigator in some ways so we're going
to provide you with a series of pillows
and
and prevention of this traumatic injury
to Columbia investigator Berkeley thank
you very much for EM gauging thank you
very much and I want to thank all of you
for coming tonight and participating in
this series we have a next Niarchos
foundation insight lecture from one of
the co-directors of mbb i Richard Axel I
would encourage you all to come richard
has been at Columbia longer than any
almost anybody else he was an
undergraduate student he has made his
career at Columbia he is a fun
interesting
tetchy guy come along and heckle him and
make this series continue in this
wonderful way Berkeley and everybody
else thank you very much
you